نعم بالفعل وهنالك الان قصف شديد يطال
العديد من البلدات الاسرائيليه في غلاف
غزه وابعد من ذلك على الاقل استطعنا ان
نرصد من حيث نتواجد هنا في جنوب عسقلان
صاروخا واحدا بعيد المدى انطلق صوب
المناطق الوسطى كما يبدو لاسرائيل هنالك
صافرات انذار في الدقائق الاخيره في منطقه
ازدود والمناطق الشرقيه وهذه هي المره
الاولى التي تنطلق فيها صافرات الانذار
هناك ربما في هذه المواجهه والمنطقه هذه
تستهدف كما يبدو للمره الاولى المناطق
الشرقيه اوه سقوط احد الصواريخ هنا من
خلفنا في احدى البلدات الاسرائيليه في
منطقه عسقلان
في يبدو انه في منطقه مفتوحه
تشاهدين الان اثار هذا
الانفجار
بجانبي منشاه سكنيه لكن لم تفعل في هذه
المنطقه صافرات الانذار ولم تشتغل ايضا
منظومه القبه الحديديه بعمليه الاعتراض
تشاهدون الان في الصوره اثار هذا السقوط
للصاروخ في منطقه الى الجنوب من مدينه
عسقلان والحقيقه انه في الدقائق الاخيره
دوت صافرات الانذار في العديد من البلدات
الواقعه في في دائره قطرها عشره كيلو
مترات حول منطقه قطاع غزه هذه احد
الصواريخ الذي سقط هنا قربنا في المنطقه
الجنوبيه للغلاف في غزه والطيران الحرب
الاسرائيلي الان يحلق بكثافه في المنطقه
وعاده ما يحدث بعد ذلك في محاوله لاصطياد
منصات الصواريخ التي تطلق هذه الصواريخ
تستطيع ان اؤكد ان احد الصواريخ كان
صاروخا بعيد المدى نحن نحاول ان نتحقق
مكان سقوطه او اعتراضه لكن على الاقل هذه
هذا الصاروخ لم يعترض هنا في منطقه جنوب
عسقلان او من المنظومات الدفاعيه الموجوده
في جنوب عسقلان ويبدو ان المنظومات الابعد
في منطقه ازدود او الضواحي الجنوبيه
لمدينه تل ابيب هي التي تتعامل مع هذا
الصاروخ لانه كان واضحا بانه قد اخترق
الطبقات العليا من الجو
واتجه صوب المناطق الجنوبيه
واثناء حديثك نشاهد هذه
الرشقات الصاروخيه وهي تنطلق من غزه وايضا
قبل قليل كما اشرت انت سقطت احدى هذه
الرشقات الصاروخيه ربما خلفكم وشاهدناها
عبر كاميرا تلك الصوره نشاهدها الان هي من
قطاع غزه